you dare enter this [ __ ] house
like a doctor you understand me right
here close to the dumpster you know me I
wish they close to home as a [ __ ]
remind the [ __ ]
it's Friday night your weeks over you
should be planning your hospital
takeover or maybe staying home reading
the book doing jumping jacks whatever
you like but always remember to include
the King of Swing [ __ ] the DEA like I
told you they can't stop us you
understand me
they tried to stop me [ __ ] 25 years
ago when I'm still alive and kicking you
understand we know why cuz I don't give
a Frenchman's [ __ ] and that's the number
one thing in your state of mind in life
you don't give a [ __ ] I don't even
[ __ ] do what you need to do young
giant put me back in the [ __ ] hole I
don't give a [ __ ] this is it nobody
bothers nobody you know sent me shooting
nobody shooting spitballs at
[ __ ] I'm just here trying to
get my life in my head together
with you bad [ __ ] that's it we
had a great week we jumped up and down
we did a podcast we worked out I got
saved I got ahead do you know I was
that's what you answer I have to look at
that's it another week of your life is
done what the [ __ ] did you do did you
make it work did you make it worth it
when did you dick around and lie to your
friends in here or did you just smoke
weed maybe didn't do dick and you smoke
weed I manage you I can't be managing
beside that that's it it's the best weed
in town this banana orgy
that's as good as it [ __ ] gets in our
world concept
smoke a little reefer for the spirits
get ready go on staging a to shows that
both sold out
and that's all that matters people give
me dirty looks and [ __ ] I don't need
this [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] you don't
make me smoking pot down that won't be a
quiet stop
I got three more joints where that came
from you know me I don't leave the house
I'm prepared there's a [ __ ] tsunami
I'm protected I got the tool waterproof
it's over I get to an island I sparked I
got a [ __ ] I got waterproof matches
an AK is sparking on anything another
light that's how I go our preparation is
key car service
[Music]
I decide that that's it you know I love
you guys we gonna have a great weekend
next weeks will be even a better week
August 15th is the new week on Monday I
put this like 28 years ago on Monday of
the 15th I was sentenced to [ __ ]
prison
and here we are smoking reefer in an
alley like [ __ ] doctors like
gentlemen
[Music]
so don't let them stop your brother you
got a dream [ __ ] em all they can suck
your dick at the end of the week it's
all about you [ __ ]
and how you gonna put it together I'm
saying and that's it that's not enough
with the chitty-chat of Joey I got two
shows to do a bump in take my oh you
[ __ ] later somewhere you know
me I like to do my little periscope so
I'm gonna smoke another [ __ ] nine
joints before the night is over
all right don't forget about me no I
love you be safe tonight keep your eyes
open don't be [ __ ] around and always
be facing the [ __ ] door
if they come shooting you got an escape
route you understand me I love you
[ __ ]